did you know that camels used to live in
the Arctic tundra yes
camels walking around on ice and snow
it's true in 2013 scientists announced
they'd discovered mummified leg bones on
Ellesmere Island which belonged to the
ancestors of modern day one and two
humped camels in fact in during the
frigid Tundra is how scientists think
camels got their iconic hump in the
first place because what's inside helps
them survive in an age when many other
animals were wiped out what's inside a
camel's hump is fat and a lot of people
think it's water but it's certainly not
it's fat and it nourishes them when
they're on long journeys that's right
fat each hump can store up to 36
kilograms of it which can sustain the
camel for weeks or even months without
food and that sort of adaptation was
especially important 3.5 million years
ago during the middle of an ice age when
the ancestors to modern camels were
hanging out in the Arctic tundra talking
about the Ice Age when a lot of mammals
were killed during that time and yet the
camel managed to survive by developing
this emergency food system if you like
some eventually camels migrated across
the Bering Strait into regions of Asia
and Africa where the fat inside their
humps help them adapt yet again this
time to the blistering hot temperatures
of deserts like the Gobi and Sahara you
see camels are one of the only animals
in the world that store all their fat in
one spot and that's useful for keeping
cool in a hot climate because heat can
escape faster from the rest of their
body which helps them maintain a lower
body temperature compare that to other
mammals like humans who store fat all
over making it a lot harder to stay cool
today cam will still use the fat in
their humps as a food reserve but
they're not the only ones in extreme
circumstances the Turkana tribe in Kenya
for example will eat camel fat to
survive
suffer a lot from periods of extreme
drought and I have seen these people
there be very very short of food and
this is difficult to believe but it's
true slit open the top of a camel's hump
take out the fat for their own
consumption and then put the top of the
hump back on again but don't worry the
camel makes a full recovery and
instances are rare but this practice has
started to generate some buzz around
camel fat as a new superfood turns out
camel fat is loaded with fatty acids
vitamins and minerals desert farms a
company that sells camel fat says that
just one tablespoon contains 40 percent
of your daily vitamin b12 needs and
three times the amount of oleic acid
then coconut oil a superfood staple and
since all that nutritious fat is what
fills the hump out when a camel fasts
for long periods its hump can actually
go limp gradually diminishing thighs
it's been in a very harsh environment
they go completely limp and flop over
the side of the camels backbone now
since we know that fat is what makes up
the hump instead of water that got us
wondering how do camels stay hydrated in
such dry climates well they have unique
blood cells that run throughout their
entire body including a few in the hump
itself these blood cells are extremely
elastic perfect for holding a lot of
water
camels can drink up to 115 liters in
about 10 minutes expanding the cells up
to two hundred and forty percent in the
process there are capillaries throughout
its body and when it has a drink it
drinks and drinks and drinks and it
swells up and it looks as though it's
pregnant if that's not impressive enough
the wild camel of China has even been
known to survive on salt water so
whether it's surviving the harsh desert
heat weeks without food and water or
even the Canadian Arctic the camel is
one of the best adapters in the animal
kingdom and that's in large part thanks
- its iconic humph